[Música]
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón y
su gobierno analizan el resultado
obtenido en las legislativas que
supusieron un duro golpe para el partido
gobernante que se quedó sin mayoría
absoluta en la asamblea nacional en las
que perdieron esta mayoría absoluta y
ante el riesgo de bloqueo político que
van a tratar entonces ahora de convencer
a los moderados en la oposición para
sacar adelante sus iniciativas el
partido de gobierno juntos obtuvo 224
escaños muy lejos de los 289 diputados
necesarios para la mayoría absoluta
en segundo lugar llegan un pez de
izquierda que ganó 149 escaños de los
cuales 86 son para la francia insumisa
de jean-luc mélenchon mientras que la
agrupación nacional logró un enorme
avance con 89 diputados en esta nueva
asamblea irrumpiendo como la tercera
fuerza en el parlamento francés un
resultado histórico para la líder de
extrema derecha marie le pen quien
anunció hoy lunes que bajar a renunciar
entonces a la presidencia de su partido
para así poder concentrarse en el
liderazgo un grupo parlamentario como lo
estábamos hablando saludamos entonces a
nuestra segunda invitada al día el es
pascal troupe analista político y
especialista en relaciones
internacionales pascal gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 le preguntó
entonces cómo se complica ahora con esta
nueva asamblea nacional elegida al día
de ayer la gobernabilidad del presidente
a más el recién electo también hace unas
semanas a emanuel macrón
buenos días a raúl pues por cierto en el
marco aunque está empezando su nuevo
periodo va a tener que aprender en
gobernar con una asamblea nacional en la
cual se van a tener que buscar
compromisos sobre los textos que se
presentarán que significa significa que
hasta hoy desde 2017 su primer periodo
de 5 años tenía una mayoría lo recordó
muy bien tenía una mayoría absoluta que
le permitió pues gobernar y aplicar el
programa su vale el cual había sido el
elegido en 2017 sin tener ningún y ni
nadie que se lo impida
el esquema ha cambiado recordó que la
mayoría en el parlamento francés que
cuenta a 577 diputados es de
289 por cierto juntos la plataforma
sobre la cual se unieron unas fuerzas
políticas que apoyaban en manuel marco
llegan oficialmente al 245 sillas
245 es decir lejos de la mayoría
absoluta pero siendo el primer partido
representado en el parlamento la segunda
fuerza es la fuerza de la izquierda
unida- las nubes en la cual existe la
fuerza de la france insumisa de menos o
lo recordó
131 días luego el tercer pilar el frente
nacional la
agrupación nacional de partido de imagen
noten con 89 y el cuarto partido
representado son los republicanos con 61
escaños es decir que definitivamente
nadie tiene la mayoría y se va a tener
que negociar para aplicar los textos
ahora sí no olvidemos que juntos con sus
245 escaños es el pilar central pero
definitivamente para la fuerza la
cronista es una reducción fuerte en
comparación a la posición que tenía hace
pocas semanas todavía claro y pascal así
las cosas entonces ya despejamos digamos
las dudas de alguna manera con qué
pasaría con mención si ganaba como pues
como hubiera fuerza en el parlamento no
gano pues como lo estábamos conversando
cuando la segunda entonces ya queda
descartado que sería el primer ministro
francés pero su fuerza política como yo
también lo estamos diciendo quedó como
segunda que qué podemos esperar de
mención y esta segunda fuerza de
izquierdas con una coalición nubes
sí entonces primero soy piloto no era el
candidato a diputado estamos hablando de
las elecciones legislativas es decir
577 elecciones que tuvieron lugar para
la segunda vuelta ayer
577 realidades 2008 es el líder de la
francia insumisa tomó un leadership
sobre la nubes que constituyó con
fuerzas políticas otras como el partido
socialista pero también el partido
comunista ahí se compuso una plataforma
la francia en sumisa cuenta diputados
más de él por casi 90 en en la nubes
pero él no es no será diputado porque no
era candidato a diputado aunque es decir
que es un líder es muy importante si es
un líder externo entonces físicamente
a la asamblea nacional ahora ahí está
poniendo el dedo sobre un primer tema
desde primer día es decir que la nuca es
definitivamente es una plataforma
elector a ver si se va a transformar en
una plataforma política acaban así unos
minutos pero las fuerzas que componen la
nube es decir que no querían ser una
sola fracción en el parlamento es decir
que los componentes de las nubes serán
tantos tantos grupos
de la oposición
en el parlamento es muy importante para
poder entender hacia dónde vamos va a
ser una oposición fuerte si va a ser una
oposición que vamos a huir que va a
manifestarse pero que va a hacer su
trabajo de oposición
definitivamente y eso desde la elección
de emanuel marco en 2017 va a ser nuevo
para la fuerza la cronista porque esos
cinco últimos años como tenían la
mayoría absoluta pues la oposición se
veían muy poco aunque la francia sumisa
tenía 17 diputados más ahora tiene mucho
más y si ya no sea un poco minuto y
medio entonces la quiero que se quede
por fuera el avance de la extrema
derecha la tercera fuerza más votada en
estas elecciones
sí definitivamente pasaron de 7 a 89
diputados estamos lejos todavía de los
289 pero es algo fuerte en un
significado por primera vez por decir la
verdad desde la quinta república desde
1958 ya tiene la fracción de la extrema
derecha en el parlament un número de
diputados tan grande hubo una fracción
de 86 hasta 88 cuando ya más lotes en el
padre de imagina era líder del entonces
hasta un plomo nacional hoy es frente a
nacional pero si 89 diputados significa
algo significa una presencia de terreno
y un empujón ahí también en el país en
favor de las unas temáticas dentro de
las cuales las temáticas de seguridad
claro y que además llegó como la tercera
fuerza más votada recordemos que marx
independizó muchísima campaña sobre todo
para esta segunda vuelta de las
legislativas y muy rápidamente porque
tanto es interese no franceses la
abstención también una de las grandes
protagonistas de la jornada 30
segunditos por favor pascal
si definitivamente el
53.7 por ciento de abstención es algo
demasiado fuerte y preocupante porque
vemos elección tras elección es que se
está ya instalando esta sesión más de un
francés sobre dos no fue a votar